yo what's going on guys crispy flakes
here with bleacher report and for
today's video we are going to be
checking out bold predictions for the
nba season's second half so yeah midway
point of the nba season uh the first
half has definitely been crazy i could
have sworn at some point i saw greg
monroe wearing an nba team jersey and
not as a fan as like an actual
basketball player on the court you know
we saw joe johnson playing some
basketball and i'm just going to toss
this out here we got the second half to
be even crazier um dirk navitzi dwyane
wade if you guys you know man i want to
sign some 10 days with the detroit
pistons i would definitely be happy
about that but yes article here by grand
two's we're gonna go through all this uh
let me know in the comment section below
what you guys think about all these
different you know talking points and
everything if you agree or disagree and
if you have a different bold prediction
let me know in the comment section below
let's get going on this uh so for the
first one here we have giannis italian
coombo will run away with the mvp award
so this one is pretty interesting
because how i view the mvp award uh yes
there's a big part of it that is team
success and you know player success but
also the narrative part of it um
and when you look at it i mean
you know one guy that i could see kind
of like challenging on this right here
is like joel embiid i feel like his
story's uh pretty good with the 76
there's no man i mean he was like top
three in the voting last year and uh you
know giannis has himself an mvp already
so
i think he's really gonna need to like
dominate to run away with it um very
well i can see him just winging it but i
can see it also being a pretty close
race because you know man you got like
steph curry who efficiency wise hasn't
had his greatest season now he's still
putting up amazing numbers like any nba
team would love to have steph curry on
the team and everything like that but as
far as mvp numbers go
um i feel like john morant has a really
good story you know man with the
grizzlies and i think he would actually
end up being one of the youngest mvps in
nba history i think the derrick rose yes
um actually i think he would be the
youngest so that would be a pretty good
story i mean you got yo kids but people
didn't really care about him winning it
last year so despite him putting up just
as good if not as you know some better
numbers this season um i don't think
he's going to win it um kevin durant's
out with injury now so he could very
well come back hopefully healthy and be
it make like a big time run and maybe
make a round at it but i think overall
um i could see giannis or embiid winning
it man i really could see this season
with maybe like a john marant out there
um also getting a few votes just for the
crazy things he's been doing for the
memphis grizzlies so next up we do have
oh there we go man john moran finishes
top three in mvp voting and why not man
why not grizzlies right now 31 and 15 on
the nba season uh john morant is a
superstar point guard in the making if
not already and uh just the whole entire
environment of the grizzlies um fan base
and everything like you can just really
feel the hype and excitement and uh john
ran showtime playing the simple so
do i think he's ready to win an mvp
award
i mean you know he's got he he wouldn't
have a really crazy second half of the
season which he already had a crazy
first half so i mean
uh
top three i i feel like that's that's a
good goal to reach for now i'm not
saying he is gonna finish top three but
he very well could finish top three um
but i don't think he's quite ready to
like win it yet man but uh he'll
definitely get some votes out there once
again man of going back just like the
narrative and what he's doing and being
one of the younger players out there to
be playing this well and changing the
entire culture of the grizzlies
basketball team it's like i know when
they originally drafted john moranta i
was like okay this is a good start right
here and then they got desmond bane and
i personally liked desmond bane um you
know there's a player i wanted my team
you know to draft and everything but
that never that did not happen but uh
he's looking like also a future just
really solid piece to a championship
team man jaren jackson it's like
and all of that is
because of john murray and what he's
able to do you know creating for his
teammates out there man and really you
know penetration the basket and
everything so
to me that's value that's value that's
the steve nash effect where literally
you being on the court makes everybody
around you a billion times better so
um yeah i love that man i love that yeah
john moran top 3 mvp voting i hope to
see it i'm rooting for him uh next up we
have two more head coaches will lose
their jobs
so i was taking a look at the nba
standings
and
to be quite honest i could see maybe one
coach losing their job between now and
the end of the nba season
but also like we said at the beginning
of the video i saw greg my role playing
basketball it's like
when you have so many players that are
in and out of the rotations because of
kovitz protocol when you have all these
10 day guys coming up you know guys that
uh no disrespect but probably whenever
under normal circumstances make an mba
team let alone play significant minutes
at times right
um yes coaching is important and there
are coaches that probably
deserve to be evaluated if they are
going to be the future you know guy to
lead those teams and everything like
that but uh i just think there's just so
many x factors things that we have never
really seen before specifically with
this nba season that it's really hard to
blame a coach on that but you know i
know frank vogel is a guy that's on the
hot seat and uh in my opinion that comes
more down to
just coaching i mean frank vogel one you
know helps them coach them to an nba
championship not too long ago
and uh
when you when your team is big you know
marketing wise and branding wise as the
lakers and you know you have lebron
james you have anthony davis you're
bringing russell westbrook and uh you're
playing pretty mediocre basketball then
yeah
you saw here in the trade rumors of
russell westbrook or frank vogel might
be on the hot seat but when it comes
down to it um for one anthony davis has
not really played a lot and uh not to
mention we know that frank vogel is a
good head coach uh we also knew going
into the season that russell westbrook
wasn't probably the greatest fit so i
mean when you're trying to force
a guy into your system especially a guy
with an ego like russell westbrook a guy
that needs to be showcased
um
it's like what are you supposed to do
it's almost like setting somebody up for
failure so i don't know if i think frank
vogel should get fired or anything like
that but i'm looking at like the rest of
the standings and it seems like
so many teams are really close in the
standings or the teams that are bad are
teams that we expected to be bad so you
can't really blame the coaching right
there um so maybe we see a head coach
get fired but i could see you know a lot
of these teams just kind of rolling out
for the rest of the season the playoffs
and then uh deciding in the offseason
okay did we like how we did last year
and do we like the trajectory of the
team going forward uh next up we do have
russell westbrook will climb to third
all
in career turnovers so
uh yeah i think when a lot of people
think russell westbrook they do think of
turnovers now i think as of late he's
been cleaning things up a little bit
better um
but as of right now i think he's like
fifth all time in turnovers i think once
lebron james two is
carl malone three moses malone four
is jon stocked and then five um is
russell westbrook and three of those
guys are not playing basketball anymore
so i think to get up to like third place
you would need to get like 200 turnovers
between now and the end of the regular
season which uh or maybe the maybe the
playoffs um but yeah it's like that's
definitely the realm of possibility i
guess for russell that would be roughly
like four to five turnovers per game but
at the same time too if this second half
of the season proves to be a little bit
more stabilized than uh you know lebron
james will handle the basketball more
you know hopefully with anthony davis
back the ball is you know simple pick
and pop with him pick and roll you know
post up or whatever with russell
westbrook and you can just kind of have
the easy pass there don't get too crazy
with it so
yeah um russell westbrook i think
has been asked to do a lot at times with
this team more so than i think he was
initially supposed to be doing
but uh which leads to turnovers with his
style of play so i i think maybe if they
especially make a big time move around
the trade deadline and you know get some
more shooters out there's more easy
passes and stuff then
probably still gonna be their time i i'm
just i'm i'm trying not to be a russell
westbrook hater okay i respect he's a
great basketball player but yeah he
might get third on the turnovers it
might happen okay it might happen um
next up we do have
the kings will end the nba's longest
active playoff drought so right now the
kings are 18 and 28 on the season 11th
place in the western conference uh just
out of the playing tournament they're
like kind of tied triplasers also 18 and
25.
so
really it depends on the trade deadline
i mean we've been seeing them pop up a
lot as far as deer and fox trade rumors
you know harrison barnes uh buddy healed
um there's been talks of sending ben
simmons and tobias harris to the king so
really there's so many different routes
this team could go in so many different
factors that could change if they are
going to you know look to maybe contend
not a content but content for the
playoffs content for not having the
longest drought in nba history uh or
they do a move that maybe sets them back
a little bit and they go for the lottery
pick and everything like that um as far
as teams that could potentially
pass them i mean you have the spurs
jonty murray is having a great season um
you know greg popovich is the head coach
so that's a team that can do some things
uh if zion gets back on the pelicans i
could see him with ingram you know maybe
making a run for the playing tournament
but even that it's like depends on zion
right and then uh
as far as like teams in front of them i
mean
the clippers without paul george and
kawhi leonard things could get difficult
there so i can see maybe the clippers
moving down
uh besides that i feel like all the
teams that are listed right now in the
playoffs they kind of belong there so i
don't really see any true uh like crazy
scenario um
unless even the trailblazers though i
mean david's out i'm finding simon isn't
playing great but that
you know that can change too man so
there is a chance there is a chance they
are close enough right now but it's
going to depend on the trade downline
and how that all goes uh and then
finally we have donovan mitchell will
win the nba scoring title so right now
mitchell is averaging 26 points four
rebounds and five assists per game uh
durant is the leading scorer right now
at roughly 29 to 30 points so i mean
it's definitely doable
i think mitchell's shooting around like
33 from three so you know i like to
maybe see that i'll take like a 36
percent type of range to i'll make
around the scoring title there obviously
and then uh you know
maybe get to the free throw line he's
getting there like four times per game
if you get that like six or seven that
would be fantastic for that to happen
but
it's definitely doable there's a lot of
really talented scorers in the mba so
when that scoring title definitely isn't
easy and i mean uh you know steph curry
whenever he's healthy he's always right
up there with it too and uh like we were
saying earlier his efficiency hasn't
been the greatest so i mean we know
steph curry can turn it on just like
that man and start averaging damn 30
points a game or whatever so yeah that
is all we have for these bold
predictions for the second half of the
nba season give me your boldest
prediction in the comment section below
thank you all so much for watching and
peace out my friends